thanks for joining us America we're
talking to Hannah in Los Angeles young
couple just got married just had a baby
or husband's working seven days a week
haven't got any debt thank goodness and
they're trying to figure out a way to
save some money and budget is tight
that's how far we got in the discussion
and then we were trying to figure out
your income Hannah and I think I must
have gotten confused so what does her
husband make a year he makes he makes
about fifteen thousand years and so it's
twelve and his main job and then about
three inside jobs okay he needs a new
job his job sucks
yes and we have we've actually gone
through sorry we've gone through three
jobs in the last year just because we've
been trying to make more mm-hmm
that's okay so does he have a degree no
he does not he has experience but no
degree experience in what mechanics so
he's a heavy equipment mechanic Reno I'm
sorry I'm struggling to believe a heavy
mechanic a heavy equipment mechanic in
the Los Angeles market makes $12,000 a
year so he makes about 12 I think it's
1250 an hour and we're not we're outside
of LA so we're a little bit of a market
yeah yeah it's kind of
he's anybody's a certified diesel
mechanic yes okay a certified diesel
mechanic working on tractor and trailer
18 wheelers should make close to a
hundred thousand dollars a year
yeah
yeah yeah so he I don't know if he's
actually gotten his complete
certification yet so that might be part
of it because they've just trained him
in job and then he's gone through and
started to take everything but but yeah
it's kind of frustrating because it's
just job after job and I'm like okay
well we'll give you 12
or will give you so we're just trying to
figure out like of course he's looking
for a new job and he's actually studying
water treatment and distribution to try
and get in there because he's also done
some of that and so we're just trying to
figure out a way to make it so that we
don't go into that and tell we can up
our job yeah how old is he he is 22 okay
well I the the issue you have is income
yes you you're not crazy spenders you're
not out of control you're not wrong to
feel like this budget is tight this
budget is unbelievably tight you are
below the poverty level
yes and so you know I'm gonna be
spending all my waking hours if I'm him
figuring out a way to change my what I
do for a living and whether he needs to
get certifications I don't know what he
needs to do he may need to work a
completely different kind of job while
he finishes some kind of diesel
certification but a good diesel mechanic
makes a whole lot more than he makes
okay and you may need to move if you're
in a tiny town in a rural area or
something you may need to make a move
to get to an area where they pay because
I mean he's making ditch-digging level
money and he's and yet he's a skilled
craftsman and so that that just doesn't
work for me
and so I I'm gonna be spending all of my
waking hours trying to figure out and
read and learn
and move and do whatever I've got to do
to get my income up because that's his
problem that's the problem you guys are
facing and it you know you could make
more than this doing almost anything
yeah and and he's working hard he's not
afraid of hard work
if he mowed grass he would make three or
four times what he's making now pushing
the lawnmower okay and just go and get
some yards to cut you know you know I'm
serious I it's and I'm not saying that's
necessarily his choice or his long term
career I mean you can make $1,500 a
month delivering pizza at night and
maybe heat maybe he adds that to the
equation until he figures this out but
but the seven days a week for twelve
thousand thirteen thousand dollars a
year that does not work that does not
work short-term that does not work
long-term so I'm gonna start changing
those equations very very quickly and
then that will answer your how do we
save money question the answer to the
question is make more in your case there
isn't you can't squeeze those make that
few nickels hard enough to make that
work in your you know in your market
long term can you survive for a little
while feed the baby and keep the lights
on yeah you can survive for a little
while but you know you know by March
first a nice double his income by March
first that's your deadline March 1 ready
set go
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]